I'm Abby hornacek I'm Ben Dominic I'm
Dana Perino and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Wednesday November 16 2022 I'm Lisa
Brady another record set at the southern
U.S border raising more concerns about
security the border patrol has to deal
with this wave of humanity instead of
patrolling the border and seizing drugs
and saving people from Human Trafficking
I'm Dave Anthony
the FBI says China is the number one
threat to the U.S and things could get
really bad if China invades Taiwan we
ignored Osama Bin Laden for instance
until 9 11. we cannot afford to ignore
China because China is much more
powerful than Osama Bin Laden was or
ever could be and I'm Carol Markowitz
I've got the final word on the Fox News
Rundown
[Music]
foreign
just a few days after the forced
resignation of his Customs and Border
Protection commissioner the homeland
security Chief Alejandro mayorkas faces
lawmakers and gets grilled on the
continued surge at the southern border
an October record of more than 230 000
migrants Crossing and sources tell Fox
News October averaged about 2 000
gotaways every day my question to you
now is can you guarantee that none of
those people have criminal records
Florida congresswoman cat camack among
the Republicans demanding answers on
border security during a hearing on
worldwide threats to the Homeland this
enforcement work is not fun
congresswoman this is a noble profession
in which people risk their lives to
conduct it and you know that very all
the righteous indignation here we go the
Biden Administration has said and
inherited a broken immigration system
but has faced criticism from some
Democrats too policies have to change
you can change individuals but if you
don't change the policies then you're
not going to make a difference at the
borders Texas democratic Congressman
Henry Cuellar says he supports legal
migration and Law and Order at the
border this as a court Fight Continues
over title 42 the Trump era coveted
related rule that has allowed the U.S to
turn away many Asylum Seekers a federal
judge ruling late yesterday that it's
unlawful calling it arbitrary and
suggesting the CDC could have used other
measures to address coveted concerns but
that rule does nothing to stem The Surge
of illegal Crossings still mayorka says
the sovereignty of the United States
Stands Strong well it's true that we're
still a Sovereign Nation but you know to
pretend that there is not an actual
crisis uh of this chaos that's at our
Southwest border we ended the month in
October at 230 000 encounters Ron
vitello is a former border patrol agent
who has served as Deputy Commissioner of
Customs and Border Protection and former
acting director of Immigration and
Customs Enforcement it's unfortunate
that the men and women of DHS have to
watch their leader talk about the Border
being secure on television in front of
Congress When anybody that lives on the
border anybody that's been in the border
patrol for five minutes uh knows that's
just not the case they're overwhelmed
down there and the cartels are setting
the agenda not the government not the
line agents you know this Reckless
policy emanating from the white house uh
has caused complete chaos down there can
you put that 230
000 encounters number into some sort of
context for us because I'm I'm not sure
that you know most people have a handle
on exactly what that means in terms of
how overwhelming that is
yeah so you think about a place like
Yuma Arizona there's probably nearly a
thousand agents assigned in Yuma
um and when the border is seeing 230 000
apprehensions a month that means in a
place like Yuma that's several hundred
people in 24 hours that are taken into
custody by the border patrol which means
that they're probably not able to send
people to the line to protect and Patrol
the Border uh because the system is
overwhelmed they're overwhelmed by
getting these people into custody
putting them in the system making sure
that they're humanely cared for during
the time that they're going to stay in
CBP custody and so the border patrol has
to deal with this wave of humanity
instead of patrolling the border and and
seizing drugs and saving people from
Human Trafficking we had over 800 people
died on the Southwest border attempting
to enter just last year that number has
never been that high in the history of
US collecting that data this is the
worst year on record for deaths at the
border and what people who live in those
communities know is those are the only
the bodies that have been found by
authorities the doesn't account for the
you know maybe hundreds more who are out
in the desert somewhere it won't be
found for years
it seems to have faded from the
headlines uh somewhat recently
especially now that the midterm voting
is over but buses are still rolling from
Texas to other states especially in New
York City
busloads of migrants do you think that's
been an effective policy by Texas and
some cities down there near the border
it matters on what they're trying to
accomplish right what they've succeeded
in doing out of Texas is relieving the
Border communities that are completely
overwhelmed by these populations
and sending them to some place where
they intended to go in the first place
right so they've been released by our
government into the local community and
the state has taken it upon themselves
to take them from the border and since
they're taking them they've decided
they've taken them to New York and the
twofer here is they're also getting
attention to a problem that's being
ignored by most of the politicians
certainly the ones uh that are in power
now including the White House they they
said that that we didn't have a crisis
on the border uh they ignored it now
they're saying it's just fine The
Border's secure the sovereignty of the
United States is still intact it's
nonsense that they've created a policy
regime that is encouraging people from
all over the world to come to the border
and to come now because many of them
won't even be encountered by CBP they
will not be arrested they will not be
encountered by law enforcement
and many of those that who are taken
into custody are going to be released
is it also maybe the labor shortage in
the U.S that's driving The Surge because
it's no secret we've got you know what
11 million or so open jobs
the economy always is a factor as it
relates to the pull from these places
but this Surge and the magnitude of it
is more than just the economy and it's
really sad you know that like everybody
wants a better life many of us have an
immigrant story in our background you
know our parents or our grandparents or
maybe even further back people came from
all over the world to make a life here
and some of the people that are in the
pipeline now have that sentiment but
along the way they get abused they get
hurt in dramatic ways people die we saw
what happened in in San Antonio with
that tractor-trailer rig it's a
dangerous Journey many of the people who
come here many people in the pipeline
will be picked off by human traffickers
and Smugglers they'll be forced to do
things that they never intended to do
and some of them are going to come to
the United States you know fleeing
violence in their own home towns and be
picked off by the very gangs that they
were trying to leave home to get away
from this is an endless supply of
recruits for the cartels and for for the
organized crime gangs that are
unfortunately in some of our Urban
centers I wanted to ask you about the
vetting process because Republicans are
you know raising concern about the
criminal records of some illegal
immigrants and whether proper vetting is
happening how does that process work and
how different is it from the previous
administration
well I think the vetting for this
population is you know there's been some
times during this surge where you know
people were released at the border
without a notice to appear in
Immigration Court they were given a
notice to report at the nearest ice
office once they got into wherever
destination that they were going to but
generally in most cases when people are
taken into custody by the border patrol
they're vetted against U.S Holdings what
that means is their biographic
envirometric information is checked
against databases in the United States
so if they are wanted if they have a
criminal record or have a previous
immigration record it will show up in
the context of that arrest and in some
cases they'll be adjudicated if they're
wanted they'll be turned over to the
local authorities that want them and
with the number last year of over 600
000 people of what the agency calls
known gotaways you have to believe that
some of those people evaded arrest not
just because of the volume and the chaos
that the board about because they didn't
want to be found by law enforcement
secretary mayorkas is denying reports
that he might step down soon how much
would that actually help or change
anything though because any replacement
would still be implementing the same
policies under the current
Administration right
it's a very good point you know the
policy is what's driving this chaos
obviously the secretary has a
responsibility to execute on behalf and
he serves at the pleasure of the
president
um and so if they change the secretary
and don't change the policy then we're
not going to see a lot of difference at
the border some Republicans also argue
the ousted head of Customs and Border
Protection is being used as a scapegoat
how much discretion does cpb have in the
way that it operates
Chris Magnus the former commissioner who
just resigned had the ability to fix
what was going on at the border and
didn't that's a dereliction of this duty
but what I suspect is happening is that
this policy is being driven by the White
House and them making him a scapegoat
for that I I don't know I'm a little
dubious about it right he's a former law
enforcement officer I think he was hired
for reasons that are very unclear but
but one of the points in his resume that
attracted him to the White House was you
know he made some statements about the
previous immigration policies of the
previous president and he wrote some
op-eds and he was he was on the record
saying he didn't want local law
enforcement authorities cooperating with
ice uh at the detriment of of the city
he he served in Tucson and so I think
that's why he was there he was a law
enforcement officer he knows what
happens in the context of law
enforcement if you don't enforce laws or
if there's no effective enforcement at
the border what will will happen will
you just get more law breaking and so I
think that might be part of the calculus
of why he's not going to be around
anymore why they asked for his
resignation and he left
in a Washington where Republicans
control the house but not the senate or
the White House
what could possibly change beginning in
January be it more resources or policies
getting tweaked or maybe nothing
well we all know the you know how a bill
becomes a law from The Schoolhouse Rock
song right so you have to have both
houses of Congress and a president
willing to sign a bill that's put up
that would effectively change policy or
change the way the enforcement works at
the border the margins are not thick
enough to get override of veto so if
this President is dedicated to an open
border I'm not sure the house can change
it using their legislative power but
they do have the power of Appropriations
right the so-called power of the purse
and then they have an oversight
responsibility and so a hearing in the
oversight and reform or in the Judiciary
with the Republicans in control of the
questioning that matters right the
agencies are going to have to respond to
that
one other thing I wanted to ask you
because the White House has said
consistently that they want to address
the root causes of this migration there
were new numbers released this week
showing the biggest migration of Cubans
since 1980 replacing Venezuelans at
least for now is the second largest
group coming over the southern border
does that surprise you is this something
that regularly changes during any
Administration
well all of the numbers ebb and flow and
we've seen the changes here it was
largely the northern triangle we saw the
large influx of Haitians in the Del Rio
last September
um then people from Venezuela took the
lead as far as the demographics and now
it's Cuba
uh so I'm not surprised because that's a
very you know fluid number and there's
lots of factors that play in but the
root cause here for the magnitude of the
migration that we're seeing is the
change in policy previously those people
would have been sent back or are allowed
to wait in Mexico for their hearing
under the MPP uh before that they would
have been detained you know back you
know several years ago when the courts
allowed for that and so that you know
it's important for us to have
relationships in the hemisphere and in
some of these sending countries if it's
possible to have agreements for
repatriation and for helping governance
and foreign aid and those kinds of
things but that's not going to stop this
flow what's going to stop this flow is
holding people to account for breaking
the law and this Administration seems
unwilling to do that
former acting ice director Ron vitello
thank you so much for your time
appreciate it thank you
[Music]
this is Carol Markowitz with your Fox
News commentary coming up
can the U.S and China get along
President Biden thinks so we're going to
compete vigorously but I'm not looking
for conflict I'm looking to manage this
competition responsibly that's right
after his long meeting on Monday before
the G20 Summit in Indonesia with Chinese
leader Xi Jinping I didn't find him more
confrontational or more conciliatory I
found them what he's always been
directing straightforward and do I think
he's willing to compromise on various
issues yes they also did talk about
areas of contention from human rights to
Taiwan we were very blunt with one
another about places where we disagreed
to underscore how serious the stakes are
FBI director Christopher Ray told a
house hearing yesterday the greatest
long-term threat to our nation's ideas
Innovation and economic security our
national security is that from China and
Gordon Chang agrees and it's not only
what China has been doing with regard to
let's say stealing U.S intellectual
property National Security Secrets
spreading covid-19 Distributing fentanyl
you know you name it Gordon Chang is a
senior fellow at the Gatestone Institute
author of the book The Great U.S China
Tech War the threats that we perceive
from Iran North Korea Russia they're
really China threats because China is
fueling for instance the war in Ukraine
with its elevated commodity purchases
supplying military information all the
rest of it and of course we have the
economic relations between Beijing and
Pyongyang and Beijing and Tehran and
this really means that the problems in
the world are actually being aggravated
by China at the moment there was some
talk that that maybe China wasn't too
fond of what was going on in Ukraine
there was also the the mention that when
President Biden and Xi Jinping met they
both uh said that it's totally
unacceptable for the use of nuclear
weapons something that Vladimir Putin
hinted could happen in the war in
Ukraine so how involved is China really
China's opened up its financial sector
to Russian institutions that have been
sanctioned and as I mentioned the
elevated commodity purchases so and that
finances the war so you put it all
together
um Beijing is behind Vladimir Putin I
know that there is reporting in the Ft
Financial Times that Chinese officials
were taken by surprise by The Invasion
that Vladimir Putin didn't tell Xi
Jinping about the war but the problem
with that narrative is that since then
Beijing has gone all in that's a reality
we have to recognize one other thing
Dave yeah it's great that China recently
has been saying that Putin shouldn't be
using nuclear weapons but China itself
has been making threats especially last
year and this year about the first use
of its nuclear weapons so this is not
just a Russia problem this is a China
problem how big is the Chinese Arsenal
there's disagreement on that
um there's a belief that China has now
maybe four or 500 Warheads some people
believe it's bigger than that that is
substantial because the United States
and the Russian Federation are pursuant
to the new Star treaty which was just
extended have limited themselves to 1
550 deployed Warheads each but China
will have somewhere in the neighborhood
maybe if three or four thousand Warheads
in the next let's say half decade that
would make it the biggest deployed
Arsenal in the world when President
Biden had his meeting it was over three
hours he said there they've talked
bluntly but they're trying to find ways
to work together
there was a piece in the New York Times
that said there were positive noises
after talks and that there was offering
a glimmer of hope even though deep
divisions remained do you agree that
there was some glimmer of hope that came
out of the meeting well I mean you can
always say there's a glimmer but to be
realistic no and the reason is that
President Biden announced that his
post-summit press conference that there
would be working groups between Chinese
and and American officials and that
Biden was sending his secretary of state
Anthony blanken to Beijing the problem
here Dave is that we're talking to China
and most Americans would say that's a
good sign that's a glimmer the problem
is as we talk China continues
unacceptable conduct and we as the
process of dialogue continues do not
impose costs don't we have costs on
China don't we have tariffs that
President Trump put in place that are
still there
yeah the second 301 tariffs that were
put in place in 2018 are still there
largely although the budget
Administration has been granting waivers
as the Trump Administration did by the
way and China's still stealing our stuff
but Biden himself has been giving
signals to American companies to keep
their factories in China so that's not a
good thing well we have given over the
decades a lot of our manufacturing to
China and all kinds of Industry
including medicine and I know people
said with covid
they wanted to rethink that is that
possible can we undo any of that or
enough of that to make a difference well
we did it so we can obviously undo it
and I think that we absolutely have to
undo it remember in the first months of
the coronavirus epidemic China
threatened to cut off the supply of
pharmaceuticals to us and it actually
did stop the flow of protective
equipment to us it nationalized an
American Factory in China making n95
Maps so uh yeah we have to introduce the
element of security in it and that's why
Dave you know I thought that chips Act
was a good idea now the Wall Street
Journal made an excellent case saying
well this will be economically
inefficient and yes they're absolutely
100 right but that's completely beside
the point we need to have on American
soil American ship making capability
because we can't rely on China we can't
rely on our friends one company in
Taiwan tsmc Taiwan semiconductor
manufacturing company makes 92 percent
of the world's made to order chips in
other words the most sophisticated chips
if we lose Taiwan we lose our chips
there's a lot of worry about losing
Taiwan to China which considers the
island nation its own territory back in
August China reacted angrily with
military drills all around Taiwan after
house Speaker Nancy Pelosi visited to
show American support and before
Monday's meeting with President Biden Xi
Jinping said
as the wheels of History roll forward
towards National reunification and the
Revival of the nation the complete
reunification of the motherland must be
achieved and can definitely be achieved
so Gordon Chang says it is a real
possibility that China tries to take
Taiwan over remember that Xi Jinping the
Chinese ruler has made it a test of
personal legitimacy that he annexed
Taiwan one way or another we know that
he's engaged in the fastest military
buildup since the second world war and
even more ominously he has been
mobilizing China's civilians for war so
this is not just a military effort this
this is a total country effort we have
got to match that if we have had any
hope of deterring him and I can agree
with President Biden as he said on
Monday that uh an invasion of Taiwan is
not quote unquote imminent but just
because it isn't imminent doesn't mean
we can just ignore it we Americans are
very very good at ignoring what our
enemies say we ignored Osama Bin Laden
for instance until 9 11. we cannot
afford to ignore China because China is
much more powerful than Osama Bin Laden
was or ever could be so we could lose
our country because we are not taking
these signals from China seriously okay
all right back up you could taiwan's one
thing you said lose our country how do
we lose our country if they invade
Taiwan
because Taiwan has become the test of
American credibility but China at the
same time is attacking our democracy and
they are fomenting violence on American
streets they are trying to create a
Civil War as we've seen from Tick Tock
and their Bots and their propaganda
networks they have killed as of now 1
million seventy five thousand Americans
with covet 19. you know Dave we don't
100 know the origin of SARS cov2 the
pathogen that causes this disease but
100 we know that Xi Jinping took
decisions to spread it Beyond China's
borders once it got out into Wuhan and
the central parts of China
for weeks at a critical time they lied
about contagiousness they knew it was
highly transmissible human to human but
they told us and the world it was not
and while they were locking down their
own country they were pressuring us and
others to take arrivals from China
without restrictions we can lose our
country because we're not defending
ourselves we do not understand the
nature of the challenge and the attacks
from China and because of that it is
entirely possible China's doing this
because they believe that the Communist
Party will not be secure as long as the
United States exists this is a zero-sum
competition and because of that this is
a multi-decade effort to take down our
government and we may think that oh
we're so strong that can't happen but
yes it can happen especially because we
are not protecting our society so Taiwan
is vital if they were to invade
do you agree when President Biden said a
couple of times the White House seemed
to walk it back that the U.S would come
to taiwan's defense more so than we did
for Ukraine we would actually be there
with our troops President Biden said
that four times in public and four times
the White House and the state department
and the defense department walked his
comments back and that causes the
confusion and that leads I think Xi
Jinping to believe that the Biden
Administration is in disarray but I do
believe that President Biden got it
right when he said the United States
will defend Taiwan because we have
critical critical National Security
interests there and it's not just
computer chips
um although of course that's important
but it's it's other things so as I
mentioned in after the fall of
Afghanistan the chaotic withdrawal after
the failure to deter Vladimir Putin in
Ukraine then Taiwan has become the test
of credibility of the United States and
we're not going to have allies if they
don't think we're going to honor our
agreements now we do not have a formal
military treaty with Taiwan but I think
that is a practical matter we have made
it clear that we will defend Taiwan if
we don't that makes it very difficult
for other countries to deal with us and
we cannot allow the Chinese to absorb
any democracy especially one as
important as Taiwan so taiwan's future
and our future are inextricably linked
and I believe that defending Taiwan is
defending America
Gordon Chang Gatestone Institute senior
fellow of course an expert on China and
North Korea author of The Great U.S
China Tech War great to talk to you
thanks so much thank you Dave I really
appreciate it
angelosi with inflation soaring and bird
flu wiping out turkey flocks some
Americans are seeking alternative ways
to celebrate this Thanksgiving holiday a
survey by online financial advisor
personal Capital found one in five
Americans have doubts about whether or
not they have enough money to cover the
cost of Thanksgiving this year turkey
has now cost a dollar ninety nine a
pound in parts of the country compared
to 1.15 cents a pound a year ago
according to the USDA to Pivot people
are switching to smaller dinners
eliminating a dish and even asking
guests to bring their own alcohol gen Z
opting for meals of soup salad and pizza
and are more willing to ask friends to
pay their share of the feast a quarter
of respondents say they're skipping the
holiday altogether some retailers seem
to be competing to offer the biggest
bargain this holiday Walmart gonna sell
turkeys and trimmings at last year's
prices basing prices on average cost
from November 1st through December 26
2021 Aldi is doing a Thanksgiving rewind
mind reverting costs to averages in 2019
before the pandemic appetizers desserts
sides beverages all going to be up to 30
percent off including cornbread stuffing
green beans apple pie even wine finally
Lidl is offering Thanksgiving baskets
that feed up to 10 people for under 30
bucks the discount is available to
anyone who's part of lidl's loyalty
program according to the Consumer Price
Index the cost of food Rose 11.2 percent
in September compared to a year ago
however food at the home category which
is food purchased at grocery stores Rose
13 percent for the Fox News rundown I'm
gianja losey
[Music]
listen to the all-new Brett Bear podcast
featuring Common Ground in-depth talks
with lawmakers from opposite sides of
the aisle along with all your bear
favorites like his All-Star panel and
much more available now at
foxnewspodcasts.com or wherever you get
your podcasts Raiden review the Fox News
rundown on Apple podcasts or wherever
you listen it's time for your Fox News
commentary Carol Markowitz what's on
your mind is there anything masking
can't do except for control covet spread
of course a new study in the New England
Journal of Medicine purports to show
that mass policies in schools work to
contain kovid but that's not all the
authors conclude quote we believe that
Universal masking may be especially
useful for mitigating effects of
structural racism in schools including
potential deepening of educational
inequities end quote sure masks how fix
structural racism why not and the next
study will show masking fights climate
change
no what this study shows is that much of
the medical establishment continues to
be intensely woke and deeply dishonest
because of it just as the experts told
us gathering in crowds wasn't okay in
Spring of 2020 but just Weeks Later
protesting for black lives matter
somehow was the dishonesty is going to
hurt us for a long time as for this
study specifically it does not prove
what the authors intended to it's just
the latest in a push by agenda-driven
scientists and the media who love them
to get people back in masks the study
centers on two Massachusetts school
districts that didn't remove their
masked mandates as soon as the state
allowed in March 2022 but kept them
until June a few months later they saw a
slightly lower coveted rates in other
districts it's amazing that kovit could
lay in weight like that ready to punish
those who behaved badly months earlier
what's even more startling covet rates
in all the schools were higher before
anyone took off their mask but that
uncomfortable fact goes unmentioned in
the write-up
plus the study doesn't look at actual
mass use just mandates nor does it
account for any differences in Behavior
income level Lifestyles and so on which
also means it can't show a thing about
maths and structural racism whatever
that is anyway
it's pathetic that in November 2022 we
have to keep pointing out the obvious
and that garbage science like this
destroys everyone's confidence in the
medical field
pre-covered trusting the medical
establishment was the default for all of
us most conservatives included I'm
firmly on the right but when the health
agencies told me in the early days of
the pandemic that masking worked I
believed them
get things quickly stopped making sense
masking outside seemed ludicrous right
off the bat yet it would be a long time
before these same Health agencies
admitted it it wasn't that we stopped
believing in masking it's that we were
lied to and then realized it and Common
Sense did not Prevail at all in blue
areas again the problem isn't just with
masking it's at the medical
establishment has gone fully woke
wokeness goes hand in hand with forced
Conformity no one is allowed to step out
of the Walk lines though those lines are
free to shift at any time it's very
Soviet under those rules you can't be
critical of even this Kaka made me study
you're supposed to see that someone
squiggled some lines on a graph and
pretend it proves something it clearly
doesn't because you need to support your
side
inside the walk Echo chamber you even
have to embrace insane ideas like
masking fights racism no one at the time
could write an article about how a study
like this is gibberish medical
professionals and journalists who point
out the obvious that the study makes no
sense will be quickly excommunicated
it's sick and it has to stop this isn't
science it's politics and this woke
cancer has to be fought until it's
defeated this is Carol Markowitz
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad free on
FOX News podcasts Plus on Apple podcasts
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
coming November 21st Fox News rewind
financial crisis 08 a look back at the
biggest financial crisis since the Great
Depression the market is not functioning
properly subscribe now at
foxnewspodcast.com
[Music]